cloud computing has completely change
the world it allows us to store and
access our stuff from anywhere making
life more convenient plus we can now
work with people from all over the world
without a hitch all thanks to cloud
computing it has been just under two
decades since the term Cloud gained
widespread recognition during this
relatively short period numerous cloud
service providers have entered the
market and new ones continue to emerge
regularly nevertheless a select few
providers have consistently achieved and
sustained their positions in the
industry so in this video we'll discuss
the top five cloud computing service
providers for
2024 but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these kind of videos and find
them helpful then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you also hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
simply also if you want to become an
expert in cloud computing and gain
handsome salary packages then look at
the wide range of cloud computing
courses by simping in collaboration with
the top universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain an in-depth
understanding of cloud services such as
AWS cloud formation Azure resource
manager ec2 S3 Route 53 VPC Azure app
Services Google Cloud platform and Mau
you'll acquire the Knowledge and Skills
for passing Cloud architect
certification such as W architect and as
your architect and you will catch the
eye of top recruiters so what are you
waiting for hurry up and enroll a year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses so check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details so what actually is
cloud computing cloud computing refers
to the practice of using remote servers
on the internet to store manage and
process data instead of relying solely
on your local computer it allows you to
access your files application and
services from anywhere within internet
connection providing convenience
scalability and flexibility for
individuals and businesses Alik so
without wasting any more time let's move
on to the top five cloud computing
service providers for 2024 according to
the market capitalization of each
provider so at number five we have the
IBM Cloud IBM cloud in simple terms is a
cloud computing platform and suit of
services offered by IBM a well-known
technology company IBM cloud is like a
toolbox that offers various tools for
businesses it helps them run their
computer programs store data and do
other essential task on their own
computers or the internet people like
IBM Cloud because it's known for being
remarkably safe and reliable it's a Top
Choice for big companies especially
those in healthcare finance and
Manufacturing because it has special
tools that are perfect for these
industries so features provided by IBM
Cloud includes virtual servers create
and manage virtual machines for running
applications with
flexibility Ai and machine learning
access tools for data analysis natural
language processing and predictive anals
hybrid Cloud combine your on premises
infrastructure with cloud services for
seamless integration security and
compliance prop security tools and other
to Industry standards for data
protection Global Research Access Data
Centers worldwide for better performance
and redundance moving on to number four
we have the Alibaba cloud Alibaba Cloud
holds the top spot among Cloud providers
in China commanding a 42.4% market share
and in the Asia Pacific it boost a 19.6%
market shet it's an excellent choice if
your target markets is in China
established in9 it has since become the
third largest player globally in the
infrastructure as a service Market
serving more than 1 million paying
customers Alibaba cloud is a dependable
and scalable Cloud platform suitable for
running various applications Alibaba
Cloud offers various Computing Services
including virtual machines containers
serverless Computing storage and
networking services such as virtual
private Network load balancing and
content delivery networks at number
three we have the most renowned Google
Cloud platform gcp or Google Cloud
platform holds 10% of the cloud Market
making it the third most popular choice
it's available in 200 100 plus countries
and 115 zones worldwide so if you
already use Google tools like G Gmail
Google Docs or Google workspace gcp is a
great fit because it works seamlessly
with these products Google Cloud
platform offers various cloud services
all running on the same technology that
powers Google's famous product like
Google search and YouTube many people
use Google for personal and work
purposes and its tools such as Google
workspace formerly known as git include
email document editing and much more GCB
collaborates with many other companies
and invest in Cutting Edge technology it
provides machine learning serverless
Computing and container management
making it a user friendly and Innovative
tool moving on to number two we have the
Microsoft Azure aure holds a big piece
of the cloud Market with over 20% making
it one of the top Global Cloud providers
it offers many services worldwide and
it's very focused on keeping things safe
Azure is really into things like making
computers intelligent by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and connecting your regular
computers with the hybrid Cloud Azure is
great if you want to use your programs
both on your own computers and in the
cloud Azure works really well with other
stuff made by Microsoft so if you
already use Microsoft's tools like
Office 365 or dynamic 365 Azo can help
you fit those with your Cloud apps also
Azo can be a good deal especially for
small businesses because it's often Che
and finally at number one we have Amazon
web services currently AWS is the the
top cloud provider with over 30% of the
cloud Market people all over the world
use it and there are lots of folks who
make things for it it all started in
2006 when Amazon created it since then
it's grown a lot AWS Works in 245
different places worldwide like
countries and regions it's like an
extensive toolbox with over 200 tools
for things like storing stuff using
computers and even teaching computers to
learn new things they keep coming up
with new tools and Friends AWS is also
super safe and has over 140 certificates
that say it's suitable for following the
rules in different countries that makes
it a good choice for people all around
the world AWS offers V features
including computing power with services
like Amazon ec2 various Storage
Solutions like Amazon S3 extensive
networking capabilities fully managed
database such as Amazon RDS powerful
analytics tools and machine learning
Services it's also known for its global
reach hosting data centers in numerous
regions so there you have the top five
cloud service providers across the globe
now the question is which one should you
choose when picking a cloud provider you
should think about a few things number
one is Services you need check if they
have the required services like
Computing storage networks and databases
features and functionality consider what
features matter to such as the ability
to grow security and the speed next is
pricing ensure the pricing is fair and
that you get what you are paying for and
lastly the support look for Reliable
support so you can get assistance
whenever you need it so with that we
have come to the end of this video on
top five Cloud providers if you found
this information helpful don't forget to
hit that like button and share it with
your friends and if you have any
questions or suggestions for future
videos drop them down in the comment
section below we'll see you next time
till then keep learning and stay tuned
to Simply learn staying ahead in your
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here